Jason is with us in Fresno California
hi Jason how are you yeah doing this
with you thanks for your time good how
can I help I got a question about a
credit score so at the moment I have
absolutely nothing in my name as far as
credit awesome so yeah what I'm trying
to figure out though no one can answer
is now my credit score beginning to drop
or does it maintain and then eventually
become a zero you should not have a
credit score if you have nothing well
I'm sorry
how do you have a credit score if you
don't have any debt in your name because
I had a mortgage loan just sold the
house in 800 okay all right I see what
you're saying yeah okay and so the only
thing on your credit bureau report is
your mortgage right that was paid off in
April in April but you don't have any
other accounts that are open with zero
balances correct no what about no other
that are open at all of any kind I don't
have any outstanding bad debt or
anything okay well here's the thing the
FICO score is determined by how you
interact with credit obviously whether
you have debt how will you pay on the
debt the type of debt you have these are
the things that are entered into the
algorithm that much we know FICO has
disclosed that FICO holds the actual mix
of those in the algorithm very closely
and they don't let anyone know that
because everybody would be gaming the
score okay right the second thing that
happened and we've just observed this
with thousands of people reporting in to
us on twitter by email and and you know
we've run a few little tests here and
there with people in classes as they've
gotten out of that from the time you
have no accounts open of any kind
somewhere between six months and one
year you usually will have a zero credit
score okay I have seen it go longer a
couple of times
but most of the time between six months
and a year your score becomes an
undeterminable because you don't have
any way to score you all right okay now
here's where it gets
interesting I want to get your opinion
on this if I may I'm in month I got into
contract to build a brand-new home in
what now I went into a contract to
perfect this home yeah when in June so
last month all right so now it is we're
going to do a credit check in September
and I wonder is my credit score going to
be dropping
I'm sure kind of how to go about it to
maintain a good school a good grade you
can't I I would tell them to well you
either have a zero score which means
they'll probably do manual underwriting
I would just tell the mortgage lender
what you're facing but I'm afraid my
credit score may just disappear one day
can you guys go ahead and pull this
because most of that paper works good
for 90 days right and they can go ahead
and pull the credit score now and just
tell them what you're facing you know I
have no accounts open and I have read
and heard where credit score disappears
somewhere between six months and a year
and I don't want that thing to just
disappear one day and you have trouble
writing this loan so because I'm
assuming you have a good score right now
what's your score now yes yeah yeah
that's awesome so you know what you want
to do is go ahead and get them to pull
that and document that it's there and
then if it pops up and they go to real
breve evaluate it later and it's just
gone then maybe they can still use that
initial pool right well if you know
about their attention and they won't
give me an answer one way or another
then I need a new mortgage company and
see the thing is we've actually
committed ourselves to them and they
gave us an incentive for going with them
I'm not coming to them if they're not
going to freak and do what I told them
to do they work for me exactly so that's
the wall Iranian seized now move the
mortgage okay and then how about the
penalties if they were charged for me
pulling out what kind of penalty they're
going to charge you 3% of the home price
no way not for pulling out of the
mortgage really okay no you don't get
charged for poni no mortgage you don't
have a mortgage they haven't made the
loan okay so they make the loan they
can't hit you with anything like that
particularly in California do so no I
mean you need to get these chirps on the
line and Jack them up they need to get
their freaking job done right if they
can't you need to go get a mortgage
company that has a clue because this is
not rocket science
I mean pull the credit bureau pull the
FICO score up while there still is one
duh I mean you know it's gonna go away
and then you're gonna manually
underwrite that and I got a feeling
these guys don't know how to do a manual
underwriting a lot of mortgage companies
don't so there you go that's what I
would do brother thank you for calling
in we appreciate you joining us hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or five
hundred thousand dollar Endicott